[Musique]
dernière séance plénière pour l'actuelle
mandature au sein de l'hémicycle du
département les élus ont validé les
comptes administratifs de la
collectivité pour l'année 2009 ainsi que
les dépenses à réaliser un budget avec
de nouvelles marges de manoeuvre
essentiellement due à la
recentralisation du rsa on a
effectivement un compte administratif
qui au total une fois retraitée de
l'effet de périmètre rsa s'élève à 1
milliard 1 quasiment donc une
progression de + lui % des crédits et je
voudrais citer la mise en place du pacte
d'urgence économique et sociale contre
le coc ville plus de 32 millions d'euros
de crédits déployer de manière
supplémentaire par rapport à l'année
précédente
et puis de manière générale sur
l'investissement départementale on a une
hausse de + 20 % des crédits 155% 155
millions d'investissements en
départementale ce qui est assez
significatif un compte administratif qui
en 2020 a déployé de nouveaux
dispositifs d aide pour pallier la
pandémie de kobe de 19
près de 190 millions d'euros sont
dégagées au travers du pacte de
solidarité et d'urgence sociale et du
plan de relance économique et social la
collectivité s'engage ainsi au plus près
des réunionnais en déployant ses
nouveaux champs d'intervention les élus
ont également adopté deux motions l'une
relative au renforcement des actions
d'accompagnement pour l'inclusion des
enfants handicapés en milieu scolaire et
une seconde sur le dispositif nécessaire
pour lutter efficacement contre la
prolifération de la dengue sur notre
territoire
[Musique]